Well, oops, sorry, wrong scene.
Sorry, it's not a movie, guys.
Woo, starting off strong.
Starting off so strong.
Where is it?
I know I'm all over the place right now.
I'm trying to find the scene.
I looked at it before I was working on it.
Okay, it's right here.
Okay, no movie.
No movie.
There we go.
Oh, there.
There's Twitter, though.
There's Twitter.
I don't know why it showed Twitter.
It was not supposed to show Twitter.
I was like, what the fuck?
I don't even have Twitter open.
That's so weird.
Oh my god, ghost Twitter.
And that's so weird.
It's like ghost Twitter or some shit.
No, I swear to god, I did not have Twitter open.
Also, there's a golden kappa.
I'm all over the place right now.
Give me a sec.
Okay, there we go.
Now it's just men.
It's okay, we're good now.
Now we just have men on the screen.
Oh my god.
All right, so, okay.
Let me know if everything is going okay.
Suddenly, just dudes being bros.
So, for those who are like, what's going on right now?
I'm talking right now.
My points are more important.
Also, Bite Size, thank you for the 10 gifted subs.
Thank you, thank you.
All right, thank you for the five gifted subs.
Holy shit, thank you for the...
Okay, awkward time for...
This is a sponsored stream.
So, this is presented by...
Presented by Samsung Galaxy Season 25 Ultra.
So, here's a shout out.
Thank you guys for all the gifted subs.
All the support, everybody.
So, give me a sec while I set everything up.
I'm all over the place right now.
As you guys know from earlier today.
If I was like, post fucking...
Post drinking, post blood moon...
Post Thursday at the blood moon.
So, like, I am all over the place at the moment.
So...
I said post drinking, post...
Post drinking, post blood moon.
So, today is the...
Today, we will be watching the 100,000K Gear Up Cup Draft.
Powered by or presented by Samsung Galaxy S25 Ultra.
So, this is basically a bunch of Call of Duty pro players or players will be playing on the Samsung Galaxy phone.
And competing for $100,000.
And yeah, 100...
Sorry, 100K.
Sorry, competing for $100,000.
And they're all gonna be gaming, playing Call of Duty Mobile.
And today, the first day is...
The first day is basically draft day.
Where I think it's like, they all see the skill level of everybody.
And everybody's skill level.
And then their teams and everything.
And then there's gonna be finals on the 25th.
So, the first day is just the draft cycle.
And then the finals will be like the actual game game.
So, just to see like what skill level everybody is.
And like what stages they're gonna be at.
It's like, it's pretty interesting.
But yes, huge shout out to Samsung.
And for picking me as a co-streamer.
This is a watch-along of the official event of Samsung.
From the Samsung US channel.
And I'm gonna judge hard.
I don't know.
I've never seen Call of Duty Mobile gameplay before.
So, it's gonna be pretty interesting.
The fact that all of this is gonna be played on their phones.
And it's like a live event too.
It's like a LAN event.
So, they're gonna be in Las Vegas, I believe.
And so, it's like 16 Call of Duty experts.
Teaming up with like, I think like four Call of Duty Mobile pros.
So, they're bringing a bunch of like PC gamers.
And then pairing them up with like Call of Duty Mobile.
I didn't realize Call of Duty Mobile has like a pro scene.
So, that's really interesting.
And then I just think it's funny that you bring a bunch of PC players.
And you're like, here's a phone.
Do what you did on PC and do it on the phone.
So, it's gonna be so interesting to see.
I wonder if they've practiced on the...
I feel like they have to practice on the phone.
But I feel like it's gonna be very interesting to see if like, you know, what they do on PC will translate into a phone.
So, especially like the different mechanics.
You have to, you know, like the different...
The different stuff you can do regarding like the mouse and keyboard.
And playing on the Samsung Galaxy.
I wonder like how well that will translate into each other.
So, I'm like...
My manager was like, don't talk about this.
Okay, I'm gonna be like, please remind me why I can't talk.
I'm gonna be like, please remind me why I can't talk.
Professional.
I'm making sure everything is good to go on my end.
Let me know if the sound is okay.
I don't know if sound guy is here.
But please let me know how the sound is so far.
Now you're a professional streamer.
Oh my god, I can like...
I don't know if you guys see this.
But I could randomly knock knock.
Knock knock.
Just randomly like, hey, I'm doing a different thing.
I'm gonna listen to this.
Oh, they're low?
Okay.
Oh, they're in game already?
Oh wait, what's the...
Give me a sec.
I just realized.
It is...
Let me put it at 1080.
Let me put it at 1080 real quick.
I think the draft stage, they're like basically...
They're not...
They're not in Las Vegas yet.
So they're just drafting to see it.
Oh my god.
Oh, is this a 1v1?
Oh my god, look at that movement on the phone.
You saw a player running around on the top there.
Some fantastic movement.
But I like this.
This is where I would be.
Right here.
And wait, I know this map.
This is like...
That's the map from...
That you guys put...
We put like 50 dragoons in.
Remember that?
This is the map that 50 of us were in.
Rust, yeah.
I remember.
I saw...
I saw Nicki Minaj here.
Maybe hoping to catch someone like this player on the outside.
You know, if you've ever played pubs for Rust or if you've ever...
You know, actually 1v1 somebody on this map.
If you get control of the top of that oil rig, it is...
That's crazy.
The amount of movement on...
This is not...
This actually looks really good for mobile in terms of movement-wise.
How are they doing?
How are they doing this?
Show me the mobile hands!
Give me the phone cam on your Samsung Galaxy S25 Ultra!
Bro, I wish I was in it.
I get a free Samsung Galaxy S25 Ultra.
You guys like how I mentioned Samsung Galaxy S25 Ultra?
You know what phone you want to buy now?
You know, the Samsung Galaxy S25 Ultra?
Yeah.
Yeah, they're actually really good.
Like, I'm just one...
Like, I can't tell which one is the PC player and which one's the mobile player.
Oh, bring up the volume?
Okay.
Boost up the sound.
I can't tell.
Oh my god, you tell.
He's on his phone right here.
His eyes are glued right on that screen.
You can't really see it because there's this, but you can tell.
Bro, move your camera!
Move it higher!
I can't see!
He's so locked in.
He's so...
Oh my god.
I think you have to like...
Especially like, you have to look so close.
Especially because like...
Wait, where...
How did he die?
He died so fucking fast!
Is the sound better?
Is it better now, the sound?
We're putting on a show here for the viewers at home.
Yeah, but it's 100k!
We don't want no show!
We want gaming!
Fight as if you want the $100,000 on your Samsung Galaxy X25 Ultra.
Guys, does this seem...
Does this seem natural?
Yeah!
Show us what that phone can do!
Might as end the game in five...
I want the mobile players to like...
Just show the PC players like...
Just how much better they are.
So natural.
As natural as the gym boss is here.
I'm thinking of buying a phone.
Which phone would you recommend?
Oh my god!
It's a good thing you mentioned that.
Thank you, NotPaidViewer105 to talk in my chat.
Well, I believe looking at this gameplay...
And seeing like how these professional Call of Duty players are playing on the Samsung Galaxy S25 Ultra.
I believe that...
To up your gaming skills and look at those graphics.
That the Samsung Galaxy S25 Ultra would be the phone that you should get.
Yes, the Samsung Galaxy S25 Ultra.
Yes, yes, that's right.
I feel like if all...
And don't you guys want to match with me, Dragoons?
We could have samesies.
I wonder what happens.
Same clan, exactly.
Oh.
It felt as much of a rust 1v1 as it really could be.
Minus the snipers.
Oh, does it sound better?
Be right back.
Thanks, guys.
I really appreciate your support, everybody.
Thank you, Endoki for letting me know about the Samsung S25 Galaxy Ultra.
I'm glad you guys know about it, guys.
It seems like a very impressive...
Oh, do you know?
Oh, I do.
Let me...
Give me a sec.
I actually do, guys.
Let me find it real quick.
All right.
Obviously, I know on the top of my head because I have the phone in my hand right now, guys.
The Galaxy...
It has unmatched power.
The Ga...
Oh, wait, guys.
Also, very beautiful segue so I can talk about this.
Not paid viewer 1543.
Unmatched power.
The Galaxy S25 Ultra is an absolute beast.
It's rocking the Snapdragon 8 Elite for Galaxy.
The most advanced processor ever on Galaxy phone.
That means a crazy fast performance and super smooth gameplay.
Even with the most demanding games.
And there's also graph...
Oh, my God.
Huskers in here?
Huskers?
Aiden?
Those are actually the only two players I know from Call of Duty.
Oh.
Wait, Huskers and Aiden are in here?
Whoa, okay.
I think...
Yeah, Shifty.
I remember...
Yeah, like Shifty, I know.
I know the other people.
Anyway, that's all I'm saying.
This phone takes visuals to the next level.
It's got a pro-scalar tech that boosts image quality by 40%.
And the upgraded ray tracing makes lighting, shadows, and reflections look insanely real in games that support it.
There's also massive immersive display.
Bigger is better, right?
So the S25 Ultra has a sudden 6 point...
Okay, actually, that sold me.
6.9 inches display with...
Nice.
6.9 inch display, nice.
With barely any bezels.
It's like holding the game world right in your hands.
Plus, it has 120 hertz refresh...
Okay, okay, guys.
It's not like this is the first time I read this.
But...
The phone has 120 hertz?
Wait, what?
Oh my god!
Bro, some regular people don't have to have 100...
Like, 120 hertz.
Wait, that's actually pretty crazy.
Yes, this is normal.
Okay, wait, I...
Bro, okay.
Like, I had the game on like 30 frames, guys.
Like, I had a 60 hertz monitor for a PC.
I actually did not know that the phone has 120 hertz.
Wow.
Okay.
I was on the 60 hertz on my PC until last week, and this phone has 120 hertz?
All right, guys.
Okay, so this phone has 120 hertz refresh rate.
Oh my god.
All right, and also you...
Okay, and it's cool under pressure.
So you know how some phones overheat after a while?
Not this one.
It has a large vapor chamber and upgraded...
Oh my god, this phone has a cooling system?
This phone is better than like 50% of PCs around...
80% of PCs.
Okay.
We got slowing down.
It's built for hardcore gamers, guys.
And then there's also comfortable gaming.
So the gaming manifrons just got easier.
The S25 Ultra is slimmer, lighter, and has a rounded display design that feels amazing in your hand.
No more hand cramps during these long sessions, especially if you're playing Gacha.
Yeah!
Oh wait, who's the first pick?
Wait, is he a pro?
Is he the pro mobile player?
Oh, he's picking one.
Also, does it sound better, guys?
I could just skip the ads so I could listen to more.
You could listen to the important ads!
That's different, guys.
My ads are more important.
That is exactly the energy we love to see.
All right, man.
Well, we're gonna let you go.
Let you brew and watch to see who's gonna be available for your next pickup that's there.
But hey, congratulations.
Really good first pickup here.
We'll talk to you in a little bit, my man.
Thank you, guys.
For sure.
All right, Lucky.
I'm not gonna lie to you.
Wow!
I was not expecting Lucky as the number one overall pick.
I can't believe it.
No shade to Lucky, by the way.
Lucky, he makes a point.
Lucky has played a lot of different tournaments.
He's been playing COD forever.
I would love to be able to...
Oh, yeah.
He should use the Samsung Galaxy S25 Ultra as the mic as well.
Oh, is that the...
Oh, that's the second captain.
How you doing, brother?
I'm doing good.
Doing good.
I didn't know that.
I didn't know there's 60 plus...
I just didn't know that like some phones have like 120 refresh rates either.
That's actually really cool.
That phones have like...
Are now like at that level.
Is it really?
I didn't know that.
No, it's not about having fun anymore.
It's 100k on the line.
I feel like...
I feel like people are like...
We say that just for the sake of it.
Yeah!
You know why, Aiden?
Because everyone...
I recognize who he is.
If I recognize who he is, then he has to be really good.
I don't know.
I just recognized the name.
I was like, wait, I know that name.
I know two people there.
I know like...
Who was...
Okay, I actually already forgot.
Huskers.
It was Aiden and Huskers.
I recognize their names because they've been like around for a while in competitive gaming.
And they're like really well known in the competitive gaming sphere.
So that's why I was like, oh, I recognize them.
Feeling pretty good about this Aiden pick.
All right.
Aiden!
Second overall Seymour.
I mean, this is a player that...
I think he picked him for the right reason.
I have no idea what they do.
Like, I think they're...
I know they're good at FPS games.
Like, I know they're good at shooters.
That's like...
Like, I was like, I know your name because you're good at what you do.
I don't know much about you, but I know you're good at what you do.
And when you look at the results that he puts down, has the results to back it.
It's the whole package.
I have a Samsung Galaxy S23 Ultra and it's pretty awesome.
Yeah, but do you have a Samsung Galaxy S25 Ultra though?
Yeah, like upgrade to the newest one.
So, I'm a competitive guy and I just love competitive.
And the right pick for that is Shifty because he is, you know, one of the best Warzone players.
And I want my team to be competitive.
Okay, we love it.
Shifty coming on through.
Now, here's the thing though.
Shifty, he's, you know, he's been around the block a little bit when it comes to Call of Duty.
How do you think he's going to fare on the mobile side?
Uh, mobile is sort of like easy to pick up.
You got maps that...
You got OG maps and like the maps...
Yeah, like Rust.
I know what Rust is.
You know, the thing you're like shooting.
That's actually the only map I know.
I was like, just like Rust.
And the other maps.
I don't know the reason why I remember Rust is just because we stuffed 50 dragoons in one map.
One Rust map.
And like you live for like one second.
Oh, I don't have money getting all new phones.
Selling my one kidney and I kind of need it.
You're so partial.
I heard we can like kidneys regrow itself.
So like, like if you cut a little bit of the kidney and then like half a kidney, wouldn't you regrow the other half?
Yeah.
See?
So like, you just...
Yeah, don't kidneys regenerate?
Oh, that's the liver.
Oh, so you're partially your liver then.
Can't you just sell your liver?
Just cut a little bit of the liver and then like have it regrow itself.
And then...
It's like...
It's like the...
What is it called?
It's like...
Like a...
Like a life hack.
Unlimited money.
Unlimited money glitch.
No, I'm cutting half.
No, no, no.
No, not half your kidney.
Half your liver.
Get it?
Get it right.
Also, don't do that.
Don't do that, guys.
Your liver is...
For legal...
For legal reasons.
That is a joke, guys.
That is a joke.
Right?
I think the first pick is clear.
I'm going Destroy, 100%.
Yes, I think that you picked...
For your omission, that might be the number one guy you want on your team.
It's the pick.
I mean, how many times do we look at Destroy when he's on stream or when he's competing on LAN?
And he's standing up, yelling at the person next to him.
Instructions unclear.
I don't have half of the liver in me now.
He's fun.
He's competitive.
He's extremely nice.
Yeah, but you talk to him and this guy is like happy to have a conversation, happy to learn.
And he is so humble.
But you don't want to get on his bad side.
When you get on his bad side, you're going to learn.
Wow.
That's OK.
I need something from you, Zim, though.
If you guys win a map, I need you to get Destroy to get up and yell, give me my money.
That's all I need.
That's your job as the coach.
OK.
Of course.
Thank you.
All right.
Well, we're keeping...
We're continuing the vibe, Copsquad.
So you got our second pick now coming on the backswing.
Who's going to be your second pick here today, Zim?
You see, and this is where they messed up.
They gave me fourth place.
So I got two picks.
I'm going...
Maybe you play better if you're fourth place, I guess.
That's what you get.
Not be flashy.
Lock in.
What do you mean they gave you fourth place?
It was a draft pick.
You want to talk about putting together guys that are going to slam and give that energy too.
And I can bring that as well.
You got a game.
You got to lock in.
If you don't want fourth place, you got to lock in.
He needs to say about Hisoka.
He is a beast and he is a winner.
And so it's like you look at a pick like that and you're doing good at putting together probably one of my favorite squads right now.
Yeah.
You're looking good already, Zim.
But you got a little bit of time to wait until we come on back to you.
Unfortunately, I think you're already maybe putting some pressure on some of the other squads.
So we'll talk to you a little bit, my man.
I'm curious to see when he kind of comes back to you.
Who's still on the board.
We'll see you here in a little bit.
Wow.
I mean, I think he hit it right on the head.
You were kind of wondering, like, how does Hisoka drop all the way down to a fourth pick?
And he says, hey, I'm building out the vibe squad that's here to win.
I think you got the two number overall picks.
And that's your goal here.
Yeah.
Guys, are you struggling to watch Jokeyboy streams?
Are you struggling to see chat?
Then look no further with the Samsung Galaxy S25 Ultra.
You can enjoy Jokeyboy's stream to the fullest and free subscription unincluded.
Thank you for doing the...
Thank you for giving me like a little disclaimer right at the bottom there to make sure everybody knows that.
So many teams or so many players still ready to get picked up and it's like...
Oh, I was like, isn't that...
Oh, okay.
So when they're picked up, they're like linked out as like an ad memorial thing.
A lot of great names still on the board, but we're gonna...
Wait, Huskers is not picked up yet?
Drop on in.
Let us know their second pick.
So Marsha, I said it was gonna be too long.
I thought Huskers would get picked.
You said you want to be competitive.
You want to bring it on forward.
Is he Wash?
Shifty in the last round.
No.
Give me your second pick here, my guy.
I recognize his name, though.
My second pick will be Adrian.
Who's Adrian?
Lil A, the young gun.
Why Adrian?
Honestly, I don't know.
I don't know who else to pick.
What do you mean you don't know?
You're gonna have a little bit of time to think.
What do you mean?
What?
That can't just be a reason.
He's a vibe.
I think he's fitting your style where he's cool.
Did you just like his name?
Let me tell you what.
There ain't many people in the game who shoot straighter than he does.
So I think he's gonna be, you know, he's gonna look to you and say, all right, yo, tell me where to post on up.
Tell me where to shoot my gun.
And he might be able to bring you some solid cash.
That is true.
Because he's younger with better reflexes.
I mean, that's a good point.
That's a good point.
The vibe drafting.
He passed the vibe draft.
I mean, that guy looks like he's vibed, though.
He looks like he's vibing.
Why did you pick Adrian?
I don't know.
There's just something about him.
He doesn't know who to pick up.
Phone a friend.
Phone one of the players you like.
I didn't!
He's like arresting his ass!
What?
You got a walking encyclopedia right here.
You're like, I can't believe you didn't research your players.
What do you mean?
I don't know.
Who's the good pick right now?
Who do the players want to play with too?
Who do they want to have on their team?
And I'm sure they are going to have so many options to pick from.
I think it's a great call out.
Ask some of your teammates that you've already picked on ups and hey, who on this list do you want to play with?
If you don't really have an idea.
I'd love that.
I see more.
Hopefully, some of our players are listening.
But let's go ahead.
We'll bring in Jez here for their second pick.
Jez, how you doing, my man?
Same, same, man.
Still good.
Just a little...
I don't really know who to pick right now, you know?
Wait, you don't know either?
It's a tough thing.
There's so many to pick from too.
You have to have a list.
Very tough.
Who are you leaning towards?
Who are you looking at?
Who's maybe on your radar?
Maybe you've heard about them before.
Anybody you're kind of wobbling between, you know?
Wobbling between Huskers.
Yeah, Huskies!
Possibly Santana.
Some good picks.
Or rated, yeah.
Huskers are rated, actually, yeah.
Wait, so then when we were watching the rest match, those were all...
That was all, like, the mobile pro players.
Okay, those are some crazy movements, though.
That's crazy.
I know more of Huskers, so I think I'm gonna go with Huskers, yeah.
Final answer?
Final, final, final answer.
Lock it in.
Lock it in!
He's picking up Huskers.
Hey, if it makes you feel better, I think Huskers is a great pickup for you.
Coming on in, so, you know, I know...
How old is Huskers?
Now I'm curious.
Huskers.
I think you're probably pretty aware of Huskers.
Is there anything...
Yeah, I was like, everyone knows who he is.
Is Huskers overrated or Santana?
Oh, he's been around for...
Yeah, I knew it!
He has one...
Yeah, it was like...
Yeah, that's why I remember him.
He's, like, really well known.
Huskers also know more about him.
Especially what his mouse and key is.
It's crazy.
Yeah, he's, like, one of the most well-known Call of Duty players.
That's why I know him!
I think Huskers is gonna definitely come on in and be able to...
Let me just see how that translates into mobile.
I mean, like, when you're...
It's, like, all the hand-eye coordination.
So it's not like it's gonna be, like, a huge change in terms of, like, gameplay.
Because it's all, like, you know, it's all...
That's a good pick.
It's all, like, hand-eye coordination, everything.
Throughout everybody on this list.
And if I was in their shoes, I would also be, like, hey, okay.
I mean, like, I'm stuck between, like, the best in the world and the best in the world right now.
It's, like, you don't know what to pick at that point.
So many good options.
I think being stuck between, you know, Huskers and Raid is a good call.
Say, Tana, if you're watching this, I mean, I'm sorry, man.
I don't know why he had to do that.
Yeah, they're all playing on the Samsung Galaxy S25 Ultra.
Because it's trying to, like, showcase, like, the gameplay of Call of Duty.
Especially on mobile.
Because Call of Duty, in general, is, like, super intensive.
In general.
And so, because, like...
It's, like, a good, like...
What's the word called?
It's a good stress test, in a way.
Especially if it's for, like, $100,000.
It's a really good stress test on, like, to showcase how well it runs on the Samsung phone.
Yeah, benchmark.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
It's, like, a field test.
Space.
Why does this read, like...
They're, like...
It says a draft pick.
So, they're, literally, like, drafting the players for the team.
I think I'm gonna have to go with Shifty, man.
Wait, I know Shifty!
Shifty's already been picked by Marshii.
Has anyone been picked?
It's okay.
He's, like, I'm gonna go with Shifty!
Aww!
He's been picked since the first pick.
He's so confident!
That's funny.
He's, like, Shifty's pick?
Yeah, he's been picked since first pick.
I'd like to steal him!
I'd like to steal a player, please!
It's, like, that...
It's, like, that game where you could, like...
You, like...
That game where you, like, stole...
You stole someone else's Pokémon.
You're, like, I'd like to steal a player.
Oh, yeah.
The refresh rate for the Samsung Galaxy is 120Hz.
Yeah, I got to pick it.
It was, literally, like...
Couldn't come up with anything.
Hit the drawing board.
I'm, like, okay.
What's a play on words?
Has to do with space.
Let's go with it.
That simple?
That we're just pulling branding goodness out of the brain?
Okay.
It's perfect.
You might be multi-talented here, man.
The six-finger claw.
You're coming out with the branding.
I love it.
But, okay.
You're here on the bend.
We're gonna give you your time while we have you here.
Give us the first pick of round number three.
Who's helping round out your squad here?
We're going with rated, man.
Going with rated.
Why rated?
Former pro.
He's got the energy.
He's got what it takes.
Aren't they all former pros?
I mean, he asked for the reasons.
I just want to have a fun time.
I just want to hang out.
And then, when it comes down to brass tacks, you're like...
I think they...
Aren't they all...
He's on 100 Cs.
It's going to win.
I love it, man.
I think this is a great pickup.
Rated E.
I was thinking, like...
Aren't they all technically former pros slash pros?
They don't come back to you, right?
I think until your final pick.
That's coming on in, man.
So, you got some time to brew.
Well, actually, you don't even get to make your last pick.
Now that I think about it.
Aren't they all like former pros slash current pros?
I'm pretty sure.
Until we come back to you.
Throw out some names that you hope somehow magically drop to you that maybe don't go picked overall that you think maybe some people might overlook that you're hoping drop on down.
Man, I don't know, man.
Maybe Nyxta.
I've seen some of his streams before.
Uh...
I have no clue.
I have no clue what to expect.
Absolutely no idea.
Wait, which was the non-pro?
Why would you do that to him?
Hahaha!
The one non-pro.
A poor guy.
But the content though.
Yeah!
That's what I said!
Talk about the refresh rate!
Of course.
Yeah!
Oh, wait!
There's more capt...
I was gonna say like...
I thought it was four captains.
I was like, more captains?
When did they add in the rest of the captains?
The comments about Santana.
No, there's a lot of like...
Okay, so like mobile gaming is actually like really popular in terms of like eSports scene.
Because they're like...
Um...
Oh my gosh.
I like...
Especially in Asia.
Because there's like...
There's like...
Um...
There's like so many other games.
Because I know there's like...
The amount of money that mobile gaming can invest in eSports is actually crazy.
Yeah, it's really big.
Especially in Asia too.
I've seen...
I've actually watched a couple of like mobile eSports.
Like uh...
Mobile eSports streams.
Just because I was curious on like the LAN events of mobile gaming.
And the amount...
Like the prize pool is actually insane for mobile gaming.
Because the amount of money...
I think mobile gaming is like the most money you can get.
Especially from like...
Um...
The most gaming you can...
You can uh...
The most money you can earn from eSports in general.
Yeah, PUBG mobile is like...
PUBG mobile is like really popular.
Like um...
What was it?
I think like...
There's like a MOBA game in mobile.
MOBA in mobile.
That's like incredibly popular in Southeast Asia.
I don't remember what it's called.
But it's like incredibly competitive.
And like really, really like what like...
It has like...
Like the prize pool is like insane.
...to Marshy.
I mean we heard Nyxta get mentioned.
We heard uh...
Let's see who else?
We heard a couple people get mentioned in here as well.
Some big names that I'm surprised have gone undrafted.
Let's be honest.
You know what?
And I just had like...
An epiphany.
Okay.
How have we not seen SpacePickupKnight?
Like he's literally would fit the Nebula Knights if you have Knight on.
What if he's a bad player?
Or not bad player.
But like what if like he's not the best player?
Maybe he's not...
He's just not first and second pick, guys.
Guys, it's 100k.
It's not about the memes anymore.
Like why did he say it like that?
Why don't you pick Knight in the Nebula Knights?
That's peer pressure.
Like why is he not picking the Knight?
Okay, let's see if Nebula Knights pick Knight.
I want a different team to pick Knight just for the memes.
The gamers.
One of the guys...
You just even look at him.
Just like how I was saying about Shifty earlier when you just...
You just look at him.
It's just aura.
The bandana, just like the serious face.
The glow of red coming out from the lighting.
The aura.
Look at his aura, bro.
Just look at him.
You got one more coming down the pipe.
Bro, he's a gamer.
So anybody you're kind of keeping your eye out on?
Anybody you're hoping that somehow makes it back over to you?
Honestly, some of my picks are stolen so I don't even know anymore.
You're supposed to have plan A, B, C, D, E, F.
What do you mean?
There's so many players that haven't been picked yet, bro.
Wait,
what?
I remember that guy because he didn't shout for like two weeks when...
When Black Ops 6...
Wait, is that true?
I can't tell.
I feel like that's something...
That's something a gamer would do.
Wait, what?
Is that actually true?
But like...
You don't even have to take a long shower.
If you can't eat, you can shower.
That's a different...
Guys, I don't think he has aura right now.
I don't think...
Guys, the aura has been revoked.
No, no, Doki.
Max aura.
I'm just saying if you can eat, you can shower.
Like it doesn't even have to be a fast shower.
Oh, that's true.
He can't be washed if you never shower.
That's how you lose your gaming ability.
That is actually so true.
Can't be washed if you can't...
If you never...
Shower.
Playing multiplayer back in the day.
So Gorgonite is my pick.
This is the guy who competed alongside CDL Talent right now.
In Long Flames, Astrial, Capsule, you name it.
This guy's been on teams with players who have been at the top of Call of Duty on multiple different titles, multiple different inputs.
And this is...
I'm just as surprised as you are in seeing how far he's dropped down this list.
What the...
Okay, that profile picture.
Wait, did they even pick him in the night?
Oh, wait.
The Nubile Knights never even picked him up.
Yeah, what is...
That is his Twitch icon, right?
Wait, how many players are in...
Bro, he's like, I don't know who he is.
But his name's freaking dope.
His name is so cool.
Wait, aren't you...
You got 4th in your draft pick.
You got 4th in your...
Valid.
Okay, you know what?
It's up by his enthusiasm.
He can turn it around.
He can train his team to be better than his...
He can train his team, I believe.
Also, Delta, thank you for the tier 1 sub.
Thank you, thank you.
And Oda, thank you for the tier 1.
I like how he's just like, I think his name is pretty dope.
I don't know who he is, but man, Spartacus.
I don't know.
A lot of them were like, I just think they're...
He seems...
A lot of the picks were like, his photo is really cool.
I mean, they're not picking off based off...
I guess because they don't know exactly what their skills are in mobile gaming.
So they're just trying to be like...
Oh, wait, there's still a few people left.
One, two, three.
There's still three more people left.
I think that's also the case.
They're just trying to figure out who's going to be able to translate their...
Who's going to be able to translate the gameplay into mobile.
It is different.
Oh, okay.
So he saw his live stream on TikTok.
And that's basically it.
Oh, he's the king of Rebirth.
I'll tell you that much.
The king of Rebirth Island.
Absolutely a shooter.
I think you hit the nail on the head.
A fantastic person.
He'll bring the...
I think he's going to fit your system well.
Like somebody who's going to help bring the vibes.
But he's competitive.
He's been playing Call of Duty a long time.
So I know you might not be super knowledgeable about him.
But definitely go check out his streams and stuff.
He's a cool kid.
All right.
Whoa, whoa.
Good job.
Thank you, Marshii for that pick.
Rounding it on out.
We'll talk to you here in a little bit.
We get all the captains back on.
And Nyxta, you were kind of wondering, Seymour.
How does Nyxta drop all the way down here?
Finally gets picked up by Marshii to round out the squad.
Yeah, man.
I mean, you said it yourself.
The king of Rebirth.
He's like waiting for a reply.
He's like, all right, everyone.
Let's just go back to the casters.
I'd say that you have that high octane fast decision making.
Casters, their entire job is to talk.
It's just like regular stream.
Like prim players, their entire job is just a game, basically.
Casters, their entire job is to talk.
So they're like, that's literally what they're supposed to be doing.
Yeah, the pro yappers.
I'm kind of curious.
Have you done some research?
Who is going to be your last and final pick?
And they're like, so did you do your research?
I've done some research.
It's like the...
Probably like when you get...
When I got towards the end of the draft is the ones I really didn't know the most about, you know?
Yeah.
It's like this can be some very like game-changing pick right here.
Yeah, and it's...
As of right now, I know...
Oh, the anticipation.
...played in the Twitch Rivals.
Mm-hmm.
So...
I played in Twitch Rivals, too.
...go there for Cindy.
Just because...
That's funny.
Alright, Noemi, Cindy Noemi coming on.
What about the other girl?
What did she do?
Realistically, right?
I mean, that's kind of the fun part.
So yeah, I mean, there's a good shout out recently.
Yeah, I was in Twitch Rivals.
Where's me?
A very strong, strong competitor coming on.
And I think this is a great shout out for you.
How are you feeling about the squad, man?
I think I'm feeling good.
Just really excited to like meet them and...
Sorry.
I played a tournament.
Oh, I heard there's gonna be like practice streams, too.
I mean, it'd be interesting to see how they go about...
...in the coming weeks.
But hey, I mean, we love having you in here.
Thanks for your picks.
We'll see you in a little bit when we bring in all the captains.
But final pick there for Jez coming on through.
Noemi, I love to see...
I mean, it's kind of a shame to see both Primrose and Noemi go this far all the way down.
But we kind of talked about earlier.
Reality is it had to be somebody, right?
Yeah, someone had to be the last pick.
The last pick at the event.
Yeah, so this is just the draft pick, so...
No, no, no.
The tournament...
The finals is April 25th at 5 p.m.
PST.
So there's going to be a second stream for the finals.
And it's going to be happening in Las Vegas, too.
Because they're making a lot out of this.
So the finals on April 25th.
Well,
I mean, it's usually the first pick person...
The first or second pick person that's...
It's second.
So the second pick guy basically...
Gets the...
Gets the last pick.
So this guy is like the second best God mobile player.
Oh!
Yeah.
See?
Winning vibes.
The draft went by so fast.
People like...
Sort of like knew instantly what they want.
Wait, what?
Nightpick's so late?
Is he like a secret weapon?
Why was he such a late pick if he's...
If he's really good?
Wait,
really?
He got the best players?
Oh, okay.
Yeah.
He...
Wait, okay.
No, maybe his team's gonna win.
No, I...
He's a coach.
Never mind.
His team is actually has the best potential to win.
Okay.
No, that makes worse sense.
I was like...
No, his team actually might be the best team.
Because like the other three players did not reason.
Bro was actually...
It was just those coach things.
Other three were just...
We're just here to game.
A good coach can change an entire team.
Basically.
Yeah, because he like actually...
He actually looked over stuff.
Oh my god, he actually did research.
Like, damn, we got a squad that can go and do some stuff.
Go and win.
The other three players are like, I carry.
But then because like I feel like...
It depends on like what exactly the matches are gonna go.
But if it's a very team-reliant game, then like it would make sense if like Zim can like basically buff up the entire team with just personal coaching and stuff.
Yeah, and the other three players are just playing with the mindset with like, I can carry this team.
I'm feeling confident.
I mean, me, I didn't do much research.
I mean, I tried, but I just couldn't really get down to the fine detail.
But I'm still feeling good.
Still feeling good about it.
Okay, I mean, as long as you're feeling good, that's what matters at the end of the day.
Marsha, I'm gonna go to you next.
I mean, you were kind of the first vocal one who said, no, I want a squad that's gonna come out and say, I want the shooters who are bringing the vibes.
And I think you might have assembled the Avengers.
The vibe Avengers.
Obviously, when you're getting ready to look at LAN and be competitive to be here.
Any sort of tips and tricks you're going to be given some of these?
One player pro can do a lot in COD, but many...
Yeah, I was thinking that too.
Like, I was like, because I remember when we played COD, one player can just hit like a 60 bomb or something and just like farm the weaker players over and over again.
But then I feel like if they can...
The thing is, if they have a team of weaker players on the mobile team, then that team is going to be the one that's getting farmed, you know?
So like, if they train up all of them, then it's harder to farm the weaker players if there's no weak players.
And then the non-mobile players can just try to farm the other non-mobile players, whoever the weaker ones are.
Because like, that's the bad part of having a weak link.
Like, they're the ones that are going to be farmed over and over and over again.
Especially for COD, when like the time to kill is so fast.
Like, that's the biggest thing.
The time to kill was so fast.
Like, during the drafting round, that was so fast.
Because like, now I know why they're like, oh, they're trying to make it flashy.
Because like, I didn't realize that like, that game, that was it.
Like, I was like, wow, that last...
That was incredibly fast because of time to kill.
It was like, so short.
Then they're all like, really, really good too.
It was on Rust, yeah.
Like, they were like, you're...
That was like, you're going down.
I mean, they get a free trip to Vegas.
And the Samson get to use the Samson Galaxy S25 Ultra.
Oh, they have lightning fast team.
I feel like mobile gaming...
Has like, more investment in general.
In terms of like, gameplay and stuff.
Because like...
Because like, I remembered when Apex got a mobile game.
And like, the amount of stuff they put in Apex mobile was insane compared to the actual game.
There's so many quality of life changes that they put in there.
That was never like, transferred over to the actual...
To like, the main game.
Yeah.
I'm sad they like, shut the mobile game.
I feel like there was just a huge potential on it.
Alright, yeah.
Oh, he actually knows what guns they use.
Like...
Bro!
The other three were like, who's this guy?
This guy was like, I know exactly what guns they use.
I like, he has a list.
He has like, a list and like, all the actual like, statistics and everything.
Bro actually did his research.
He actually watched streams.
He actually did his homework.
Oh, it's single elimination too.
That's scary.
Because of how fast these games are, single elimination is actually so fast.
Yeah, it's...
He won Twitch Rivals?
Bro, what?
Why didn't they...
Did they...
Bro, just...
They could have googled.
They knew that who was in there.
...keep flaming him.
Picks up Huskers.
I think it's between Huskers and Rated.
Well, he grabs Huskers but thankfully for him, Dante still there on the back side.
Had that kind of last choice between, you know, either obviously coming on in and being able to pick up, you know, do you want Noemi?
Do you want Primrose?
Goes for Noemi.
I think that's gonna be a fun squad to watch in Vegas.
Let's talk a little bit about this Nebula...
It's just a draft day.
The actual games will be on the 25th.
So we're just learning about the players right now and like who they're drafting.
Like I said, you know, Knight could have had his evolution into like the next...
I mean, the thing is all the non-mobile players are starting off zero.
So they have a huge room to grow.
Because like what I think is that...
This is how I feel about when players learn a new game or learn a new character.
It's easier to train a player when they're starting off zero.
Because they have no background knowledge of like other mechanics and stuff.
So like I assume a lot of these players in the original in the...
Oh my god, thank you for the raid!
Sakura, thank you so much for the raid!
I hope you have a great stream!
For those who are new here, my name is Dante.
I'm currently doing a...
I am currently looking at the draft day for the gear up draft.
Powered by Samsung Galaxy S25 Ultra.
Well, hello everybody!
Hello, hello!
I usually stream on YouTube.
But today, I have a stream presented by Samsung Galaxy.
Samsung.
So that's why I'm on Twitch right now.
But thank you everybody for coming!
Thank you so much for the raid!
I really appreciate it!
Hello, hello!
Okay, so there's draft day.
So these are like all the players that are doing their practice streams.
So if you guys want to see how they do...
Honestly, which one was Zim's team?
I'd be interested to...
Yeah, the rare Twitch Doki.
Yeah, how's it gonna be?
Okay, best of five.
Snake style.
I always feel like it's...
Okay, yeah.
There's 16 Call of Duty pros and influencers.
I hope they have like at least like four influencers.
I feel like each team should have like a mandatory pick of the influencers.
Because it's not fair to like...
I feel like it's...
I'm not saying it's not fair.
But like it is harder for them.
Also, Medi!
Thank you for gifting a tier 1 sub for Abra Kadabra.
Thank you, thank you!
At least everybody.
Yeah, everybody wins something too.
Hard point.
Call of Duty Mobile Pros 1v1 free-for-all.
What's hard point?
Best of five.
One, two, three, four, five.
So then it'll stop at free-for-all.
Free-for-all, Zim.
It could stop at free-for-all or search and destroy.
Oh, is it control points?
Okay.
So they do have...
Wait.
Call of Duty Mobile Pros 1v1 free-for-all.
Is it just the team captains?
Is the 1v1 free-for-all just for team captains?
Oh, the show matches.
That's the fun part.
First place gonna pick up that $10,000.
Second place to pick up the $5,000.
I think lots to look forward to when we get to that LAN.
Lots of free-for-all.
Lots of opportunities to earn this $100,000.
I think if you're interested in how the Call of Duty matches will become the mobile matches.
The practice room would be a good time to watch and see.
And to see how they grow from there.
And learn from...
Learn Call of Duty Mobile.
Because they're usually the ones where they're explaining the mechanics and everything, too.
Can I join the show match?
Allow me to Las Vegas.
Guys, exclamation point leveled up in chat, guys.
No, I'll do it.
Oh, wait.
I have incognito mode.
I can't.
I have to be off of...
Guys, exclamation point leveled up.
I can't.
I'm on incog.
Wait, most powerful processor?
That's nice, though.
I hate it when phones like...
Like,
if you play too long on your phone, it heats up and stuff.
That's really good.
I mean, that's true.
I mean, like, that's true of your career.
It guards, like, graphics and stuff, too.
Got, like, better...
Better gear for it.
Yeah, serious phones are serious, guys.
You know what's a serious phone for serious gamers?
Samsung Galaxy S25 Ultra.
It's actually...
I'm still, like, blown away that it has 120Hz refresh rate.
Like...
I didn't realize phones could do that now.
Like, I didn't realize phones can go above...
Like...
I don't know.
I never thought of it that way.
I never realized, like...
Oh, does that act...
Wait, better cooling also means battery lasts a lot longer?
Oh, is that what cooling does?
The S stands for...
The S stands for serious.
Wait, is there GT...
Is there GT on phone?
Heat pad.
Oh my gosh, I'm learning so much.
Like, that's really good.
I always have my...
I always have my phone plugged.
Which is not great.
Also, don't do that.
Don't always have your phone charged.
Because it actually...
It actually lessens the battery life on your phone.
You always have it charged.
Oh, is it Zim?
I only remember one guy's name on top of my head.
It was like Zim...
Oh my gosh, and the...
My...
Something, something...
His name is the easiest.
Oh, it's Zim, Jez, Space, and Marshy.
There you go.
Thank you to the person that did !practice.
I really appreciate it.
Friendly
Italian restaurant with outdoor seating nearby.
And texted to Luca.
Oh, is this the phone?
I can never bring dad to a restaurant.
Because he's too much of a nuisance.
He's like...
Yeah, he's too food hungry, man.
I can...
He's too silly.
He's just a silly little guy.
Yeah, but yeah, that was draft day.
That was...
That was like included in the...
That was included in the...
Guys, guys, I have...
I have turbo, guys.
I like how you're...
Okay, what's funny?
It was that...
What was funny was that...
My manager thought that was an ad from like Twitch.
But it was literally just like on the channel.
Because he was messaging, he was like, skip ad.
I was like, what?
I have turbo.
I didn't see...
I didn't see the ad.
But yeah, that was interesting.
Um, huge thank you to...
Um, Samson.
Um...
Samson for uh...
Inviting me and checking out the...
And checking out the uh...
Draft day for it.
But this is just like the beginning of the stream.
The beginning of the whole event.
Obviously, it was just them getting to know the players.
And getting to know like...
Oh my god, I can knock knock.
You want to do a collab right now, Samson US?
Knock knock!
I know your stream is ending, but you want to...
It's like, knock knock!
You want to do a collab right now?
Um...
But yeah, it actually is...
It was pretty interesting just to see like how...
How everything was going to be set up.
And what the format is.
And just getting to know the teams in general.
And getting to see like...
What the format's going to be.
I think it'll be very interesting to see how they're going to train the players.
And the non-mobile players.
And it become...
Into being like, you know, really good...
Really...
Really good mobile gamers.
Like I was...
Oh yeah, I was going to say.
It's easier to train someone with zero knowledge...
Going in than it is with someone that's been a part of the...
Mobile...
Like...
I think it's been part of the...
Part of the scene.
Because like...
They don't have knowledge from before.
That's hindering them.
So like...
So they're like...
Oh, but like...
Oh, I used to do this and this before.
But you're like...
Oh, well, it's different.
Because this is different.
This is a different game.
This is a different mechanics and everything.
So it will be interesting.
Because a lot of these players are coming in with like...
Maybe they never tried Call of Duty mobile before.
Maybe this is their first time on mobile gaming.
So it's going to be interesting to see how they progress from there.
And if they become like, you know, insane gamers in general.
And they're all going to be playing on the same phone.
So they're all going to be playing on the Samsung Galaxy S25 Ultra.
So because they're all playing on the same phone.
Then there's no actual...
It's all going to be the same devices and everything.
So they're all going to be equally the same in terms of technical side.
Yeah, the same platform and everything.
But yeah, I think...
Honestly, I'm just stuck on the fact that it has 120Hz refresh rate.
I think that's the most interesting part regarding...
Like, I used to game on 90Hz.
So it's like, oh my god, I could have done this all on phone.
But yeah, the Grand Finals are in Las Vegas.
Which is cool.
Las Vegas is expensive.
They get to...
If you win, you get to party in Las Vegas.
If you lose, you get to party in Las Vegas.
Like, it's a win-win.
It's a win-win, guys.
Winning or losing, what happens in Las Vegas stays in Las Vegas.
But yeah, huge thank you to Samsung.
And I hope...
I hope to see, like, what...
I hope to see, like, which team's gonna be on top.
I hope Zim's team is actually a performer.
It'd be very sad if, like, you know...
Zim did so much research in general.
He did so much research and then, like, you know...
Fall flat in the end.
Because this guy actually, like, looked up the players.
Right there, right there.
Watched the...
Watched players' streams.
And, like, read what their, like, strong points are.
So, like, I hope that...
Because he's apparently the weakest mobile pro player.
So, like, as a coach, he should be able to train everybody.
Yeah, imagine losing to Vybz.
I would be sad if I...
If I was a coach and, like, I lost to a guy who just picked based off, like, Vybz off of...
No, okay.
That guy picked players based off of photos.
I thought that was...
I thought that was so funny.
He was like, bro, look at this guy's photo.
And I was like, what do you mean look at this guy's photo?
Wait, wait.
Actually, let's see.
I want to look at the 1v1 again.
I want to look at the...
Okay, let's see the 1v1.
I'm curious.
All right.
Because the 1v1s were like...
I didn't realize that it was...
Okay, I want to see the 1v1s again.
I'm gonna re-watch the 1v1s real quick.
There we go.
The photos look promising.
Okay, so these were the pros.
Oh my god.
Like...
Like, oh my god.
That's so fast.
Like, that movement?
Like, I'm just...
Headshot?
Okay.
Yeah, I was so surprised.
Oh my god, look at him just running around.
He's like, get out of here.
Get out of here.
Like, I'm just looking at the buttons he's pressing in general too.
Is it like...
Okay, it's 1v1.
Oh, are they wearing the...
The finger...
The little finger gloves?
So you know how like on PC, people sometimes wear like those arm sleeves and stuff?
For mobile gaming, it's like those little finger gloves.
And you were just using that just to fly around this map.
Maybe hoping to catch a timing on somebody like this player on the outside.
You know, if you've ever played pubs for roster.
If you've ever, you know, actually 1v1 somebody on this map.
Jesus, it's so fast.
It's so fast.
Oh my god.
Oh my god, look at that guy's move.
Movement's not gonna save you.
Wait, is this the gun sound?
Oh my god, I would be so annoyed.
Like, I don't know how you...
Okay, the gun looks really cool and the depth animation is really cool.
But it's like...
Peep, peep, peep, peep!
Like, I won't be able to take that serious.
Omni movement can't help you on mobile.
Omni movement is not gonna help you on mobile.
That guy's like...
Oh,
they put all four of the players in rust.
Okay, I thought it was like individual 1v1.
That's... it was literally...
It was one round.
It was one round because it was whoever...
It's like whoever has like...
Whoever makes it to 21st.
That's why.
Okay, that makes more sense now.
Nearly just one guy like killed everybody.
Yeah.
It is actually like...
That's why.
I like the three half comes to end and the one guy with the basic loadout.
Okay, that's aura.
That's me like me.
I was like, I don't need cosmetics to kill you.
Like...
That's...
That... okay.
I like...
It's really funny because people who do that...
Like, they don't use...
They use... they're like default Andes.
People who do that, it's more so of like...
It's like...
They think you're a hacker.
It's more funny that way.
They actually think you're a hacker if you don't use like any skins.
They're like...
Yeah.
I think that's...
He's definitely...
He's aura farming right there.
Oh wait, he's fourth place.
Never...
Never mind.
He farmed too hard.
He might have farmed too hard.
He's negative aura farming.
He was the...
I didn't realize he was the coach, guys.
Okay, which one was the...
Okay, I wonder...
I think it was the one with the...
The crystal one.
Oh, that's cool.
That's a good reload.
One of the things I love about Call of Duty Mobile here, Colin...
It's too much aura.
Not enough points.
...who loves my gun looking cool.
And every time I'm able to cast or watch Call of Duty Mobile...
Ugh.
I just get a little jealous.
I'm like these...
Everything looks so crazy.
I don't even know what...
I want to know who's first.
Are they the crystal?
Oh no, it's this guy.
This guy.
The one with the hardcore gun.
Oh my...
Jesus.
Oh my god.
Wait, he has like...
A little whip.
Oh, is he the number one seed?
He's one point.
Not one tap, bro!
Oh, he was the six-figure.
The six-figure claw player.
That was like...
Jeez, that's...
Okay.
My god, third...
Okay, so...
Let's see.
It's three...
Oh my god.
That guy like actually farmed.
That guy...
Okay, but like how much...
What was the fourth place?
Wait!
Bro!
Did they even show the fourth?
How many kills the fourth place player get?
Oh, Zim.
Zim.
Wait, I want to know how many kills Zim got.
His aim on mobile is actually crazy.
One more kill.
Is it actually a one tap?
Who did he kill?
Oh, Vitality.
Okay, is that a second place player?
Oh, wait.
Who did he kill?
Who's Vitality Peanut?
Is that Zim?
Wait, was that Zim?
Wait, give me a sec.
I need to...
Wait, did he kill Zim for the...
For it?
Oh, yeah, he did.
That's unfortunate.
That's unfortunate, guys.
Oh, man.
Oh, buddy.
Okay, don't worry.
Don't worry.
He can coach the rest.
I think it is scary because I think like...
Space is playing in more so of like...
More so like...
But then his KDA is not...
Space is more so like...
I'm gonna kill as many as I can as fast as I can.
And...
And it's working for him.
So it makes more sense.
His gun is a marksman rifle as well?
Is that like...
That's like a 30-30, right?
Nice shot up towards the top.
One of the things I love about Call of Duty...
Is that like a 30-30?
I think Call of Duty skins are actually pretty funny and cool.
There's a lot of really...
I saw like...
There's this guy on Twitter that does like...
Call of Duty reload animations.
And there's like some really silly ones.
Because there's like what the rare ones, right?
Oh, it's more like a G7.
I mean, it's all about being accurate.
This guy's like just trying to be as accurate as possible.
So he has the aim for it.
His aim is crazy though.
Like it does not...
Like it's actually so accurate.
I just want to know like...
I want to know like how many kills fourth place guy got.
It's better than...
I saw like...
There's like rare...
Was there like rare animations, right?
For Call of Duty in general.
There's like rare animations and stuff you can get from reload animation.
I think like...
I think Call of Duty...
I wish like Call of...
Oh my gosh.
I wish like other games do like the funny stuff that Call of Duty does.
Like...
Like the realistic collabs and stuff.
Tie-ins.
Isn't that...
It's like...
Oh, okay.
I mean there's some like silly ones in Call of Duty too, but...
I love the collaborations that...
Collaborations that Call of Duty does.
Because they're all...
Like they're all really funny and silly and I like that.
But yeah, that was interesting.
It was really interesting to see.
Like getting my glimpse into...
Into like mobile gaming and the mobile esports scene.
I have watched other mobile gaming before, but I don't...
I think I've mostly watched like MOBAs and...
MOBAs and...
Oh my gosh, which one was the other one?
There's like a really...
I forgot.
I forgot what it's called.
But like it's one of the famous mobile games that I always see ads for.
Um, but this is the first time I've ever watched Call of Duty mobile gaming.
And just to see like how it goes.
And like the movement is crazy though.
The movement and aim.
And then you have to be very precise too.
Because like, you know, obviously like PC monitors...
Size versus like mobile size is like a lot different.
But it does have like the graphics for it.
Like the cooling and the higher processor graphics and everything really helps out a lot.
Especially if they're all playing on like the Samsung Galaxy.
That's 25 Ultra.
So, um, I assume like the graphics quality is like a lot more precise and sharp too.
And then there's the 120 hertz as well.
But yeah, it's very interesting to see.
I look forward to checking out the finals later.
Um, it was a very short stream.
Um, it was just draft day.
I assume the...
I assume the finals is going to be a lot longer.
Because obviously it's best of five.
It's a competitive sense.
So we're going to see a lot of people competing.
And there's going to be show matches and everything.
Best of five with show matches.
Not just like a free-for-all.
So I look forward to checking it out on 25th.
And I hope you guys, uh, check it out with me as well.
Like show up on stream and watch it with me, guys.
Anyway, I hope you guys had a fun time with me.
I hope you guys do check out, um, the tournament.
The Gear Up Cup Trap...
Not draft, sorry.
Gear Up Cup Finals on April 25th.
It doesn't start at 4 p.m.
It does start at 5 p.m.
PST on the 25th.
I might stream a little...
I'll stream a little earlier for it.
Um, I'll stream a little earlier for it, uh, for, uh, the draft.
I was going to be planning on streaming a little bit...
Starting early for this one.
But like, I was feeling sick.
Ha ha ha ha.
So I couldn't start right away.
Um, I couldn't start right away.
Because like, you guys know why I was feeling sick.
So...
Ha ha ha ha ha.
And I also had to walk my dog too right before.
Oh my gosh, my dog was like...
My dog was so...
Okay, dad was so rude today.
He was...
During his walkies, I was supposed to like...
I was supposed to...
The moon.
I was supposed to like...
Come back earlier to my PC.
But then he decided to...
He decided to be like, you know what?
I'm gonna do my business twice.
And I'm gonna make you walk back to the trash can.
I...
Ha ha ha ha ha.
I was like, please!
I have to go back to my PC!
I need to stream!
I have...
I have to stream!
It's like, nope.
And then he like, walks further away from the trash can too.
He's like, we're about to cross the road to back home.
And then he's like, you know what?
I'm gonna...
I'm gonna poop here.
So then I have to walk all the way back to the trash can.
Which is like, you know, at the end of the other side of the walkway.
At the sidewalk.
I have to walk the other side to the end there.
And I'm like, please!
And then there was like, six dogs outside too!
And he hated all of them.
He...
He hated all the dogs.
So I had to like, grab him.
I legitimately like, couldn't...
Like, the thing is, the moment he saw them, he freaked out too.
He hates poodles.
I don't know why.
He really, really...
There were like, three poodles being walked during that time.
And he hates them.
Like, he saw one poodle and he was like, no!
He freaked out!
So then like, and I was like, okay, I'm just gonna drag him away.
And then I had to like, and they're all...
And then I had to pick him up.
Because at that point, like, I couldn't deal with it.
I was being surrounded by other dogs.
No,
they were big poodles!
They were the big fancy poodles!
Where you had to like, get them shaved and trimmed all the time.
And so, he was like, he was so annoyed.
He was like, I hate them.
And then, like, we were surrounded by six other dogs being walked.
So I had to actually pick him up and like, pick him up and bring him home.
Because he wouldn't, he refused to like, move.
Like, he was, he was trying to pull me in all directions.
Trying to like, get, get at one of them.
And then like, even when I picked him up, he was like, he's like, I'm gonna get you!
I'm gonna get you!
He was just like, he was like, I'm gonna get you!
You think because I'm being, I've got upsies and I'm still not threatening?
So, I had to deal with that so that I couldn't start my stream earlier.
But yes, for the 25th, I will start my stream earlier.
Just so like, people can like, come in before the actual tournament starts.
And we can have a little chat too, before it starts too.
I hope I, by then I will most likely not be like, feeling sick before the stream.
And having to like, readjust my brain for the stream.
And everything.
But yes, thank you again.
I hope you do check out the phone, the Samsung Galaxy S25 Ultra.
I hope you do check it out.
It does have, I mean, 6.9 inches is nice up on display.
And the refresh rate and everything.
And also, graphing processor.
But yeah, I hope you guys do check out the phone.
A huge thank you for the support from Samsung.
And for letting me be one of the official co-streams.
Hey guys, I'm gonna head off now.
If I don't raid, you guys can randomly disperse.
I don't know, sometimes I just feel like not raiding.
I don't know.
It's just hard trying to figure out who to raid, okay?
It's just really hard.
I hate making decisions sometimes.
So if there's no raid, just randomly disperse to wherever you want to go to.
I mean, I could raid one of the...
I'll just raid one of the people that's competing.
How about that?
Let's see.
Maybe one of them are still doing the stream.
They'll be like, who the heck is she?
And then I'll be like, hello and peace out.
Maybe, you know what?
Yeah.
Maybe I'll raid one of...
Wait, do they have...
Oh, never mind.
Sorry.
Are they all on YouTube?
Wait, are they all...
Okay guys, never mind.
I think they're all gonna be streaming it on...
Are they all streaming on YouTube?
Where's their Twitch?
Okay, let me look.
Guys, let me look real quick to see if they have...
Uh...
Wait, they're all on YouTube.
Are they actually?
Let me check real quick.
Jazz.
I don't know.
I'm looking guys.
Three nukes, back to back to back.
Oh, sorry, that's his...
Twitter.
Wait, are they actually?
Oh, aw I wanted to...
I wanted to like, raid them on Twitch if they're on Twitch.
Aw, okay.
Let's see.
Alright.
Most likely, I'll just be like, disperse.
Find your home.
I hate choosing.
Find where you wanna live.
Find a... oh, you know what?
I'll raid.
You know what?
I know who to raid.
Alright.
Alright, I know who to raid.
You don't have to find a home anymore.
I will bring you a home.
Alright, I'll see you guys later, everybody.
As always, everybody...
Stay hydrated.
Posture check.
Get up a bit more and move around to get that blood flow.
And you stay up for me?
Head to bed, cause you deserve it.
I'll see you guys next time, everybody.
Bye, guys.
Bye!
Also, check me out on YouTube, cause I usually stream more on there.
Sorry, my brain's all foggy right now.
Bye-bye, everybody.
Bye!